we're we're
pretty close to the same age uh i'm 46
next month one month from today and uh
i graduated from high school class of
1992.
you were the you were the first pick of
the 1992 draft
and of course
and i looked up uh the 1992 draft
and and not i didn't look up shaquille
o'neal i just looked up the 1992 draft
and it said it was one it was widely
considered to be
the deepest draft of all time
at that time and you were
i number tell you i'm a bad sun gun yeah
okay so now check this out ah
i went to the university of miami right
you
you went to lsu there's no beef there
but uh and whatever man i failed out so
[ __ ] fast man i was only there for
that
for that one first year but i had i had
this girlfriend
right now in 1993 i was my only year
there
i had this girlfriend that was your
rookie year
with the orlando magic okay now me me
and my girl we're in
her dorm room in the dorms okay we're
we're doing our thing we're having sex
okay the tv is behind me
i'm just like regular old missionary
style the tv's behind me and i hear this
like newscaster
like uh maybe it's sportscenter i don't
know what it was but it said
it said on the tv but i just heard and
it's the shack attack
shaquille o'neal like you know rookie
for the orlando magic
shatters the backboard and in the middle
of having sex
i i'm like i gotta [ __ ] see this i
just stop and turn around
to to watch the tv then dude this girl
was so [ __ ] angry
she like i do we didn't finish man she
like
get the [ __ ] off me she wasn't even
having it dude i had never been in
trouble with a girl like that and i'm
like what
what do you want i had to see that
apologize oh man dear sorry so you hold
the record for the most shattered
backboards
i think like seven or eight no i really
we understand it to be 19.
you caught me and including high school
and parks and gyms
i remember one time i was in sports club
la and i ripped the whole goal around
the manager who's gonna pay for
that's crazy man thank you so much for
watching this clip
and guess what i have the number 30
ranked hot sauce on all of amazon
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude